la ryder cup est aujourd'hui la plus
grande compétition de golf au monde
créée en 1927 par samuel ryder un homme
d'affaires anglais au rendez-vous et
aujourd'hui regardés par un milliard de
téléspectateurs à travers le monde et
rassemble près de 250 mille supporters à
chaque édition c'est un roland garros x
20 c'est c'est une chance c'est des jeux
olympiques c'est c'est quelque chose que
le public français va probablement avoir
la chance de voir une fois dans sa vie
sur le plan sportif la ryder cup oppose
les 24 meilleurs joueurs au monde 12
européen et douze américains sur trois
jours de compétition au rendez vous est
organisé tous les deux ans en alternance
aux états unis et en europe sur les plus
beaux golfs internationaux cette année
c'est le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qualité a
sélectionné quant aux règles elles sont
simples et indémodable 16 matchs en duo
sont programmées le vendredi et le
samedi dimanche tous les joueurs
s'affrontent en face à face chaque duel
rapporte un point au gagnant un demi
point distribué à chaque joueur pour un
match nul la première équipe à atteindre
le score de 14 points et demi est
déclaré vainqueur de la ryder cup en cas
d'égalité c'est l'équipe tenant du titre
qui soulève la coupe au niveau du
calendrier un match entre célébrités
européennes et américaines est
programmée le mardi le mercredi ce sera
au junior de s'affronter dans un match
amical le jeudi une série d'ouvertures
est organisée avec la présentation des
équipes et un concert géant à
compétition débutera officiellement le
vendredi 28 septembre pour se terminer
le 30 septembre avec une remise des
trophées à 18 heures